Walmart you've probably heard of them
they're probably in your neighborhood
destroying the local economy right this
very second they were find this week 82
million dollars for violating the Clean
Water Act basically you can guess what
this is I mean they're just dumping crap
in to the water we then drink the water
we wash our faces with the water all
that good stuff this was they violated
six counts of the Clean Water Act it was
filed by prosecutors in LA and San
Francisco they disposed of chemicals
improperly all this and you can guess of
course they have the money and there's
no reason to think they're ever going to
change is there anything we can do to
stop you know we talk about this stuff
all the time Young Turks is built on
trying to sort of stop these giant
corporations from doing all these evil
things and abusing money and power and
politics is there anything that can be
done with this stuff where it's just
like I pay the fine move on and that's
it pay the fine yeah I don't know I'm
really not surprised that this happened
cuz I see a lot of butt cracks go in an
Ottawa not surprised so you think
there's a correlation between butt crack
and crap and crap but there is thank you
yeah a little bit yeah Whitney is there
anything we can do to stop these giant
companies from doing this kind of thing
you know unfortunately money talks in
this country and it will buy your way
out of anything literally they will pay
this fine in twenty five point four
hours of their time that they're open
for so it's like you know a drop in the
bucket not even you know it's like mist
yeah and and I think that until I don't
even know a solution I don't even know I
think if anything that would even
remotely affect anything would be
putting people in jail and holding
people personally accountable right but
that will never happen because they have
that executives don't go to jail in
America we don't know bankers go to jail
or no corporate executives ever go to
tailor that work there are gonna go to
jail right well that's the point I mean
none of these people ever bother me the
most like they think that in big oh you
know just arrest all of them exactly
that'll be fine
you know but it's like that's funny like
they're gonna fire the guy who literally
like polish which the minimum wage
driver was like oh yeah but that would
be what would happen most likely you
know and it's just like oh man and they
will never be held accountable and the
the one thing that really just ticked me
off was in reading it you know the I
think vice president or something like
that said one of the first responses was
that we're pleased with the outcome and
this will not affect our fiscal quarter
right because that's what it's all yeah
the fiscal quarter yeah so if we can't
do anything about these companies are we
all to blame because I truth be told I
moved here a couple months ago I did go
to walmart and I was going to buy a TV
and actually they were service there was
literally so shitty I brought the TV up
a 50-inch TV carried it to the register
and the service Micheaux so shitty I
just left it there unless yeah but I do
shop at Target all the time and you know
I got my grill it loads or outflows kept
just tossing them I get my body heals
yeah my point is we all do this stuff so
are we all to blame because I'm guessing
you guys have both probably shopped at
walmart right like in the past yes I
have officially given it up though okay
i will say companies like that should be
ashamed of themselves for doing
something like that but at the end of
the day are we to blame yeah do we do
this in our everyday lives too yeah
without knowing it are we dumping
chemicals without knowing it yeah all
the time like regular people are doing
it too so I mean just playing devil's
advocate here you know a lot of people
are not informed yeah at all have you
have you guys seen these new commercials
for Walmart where they now are
pretending that they're getting all the
stuff from local produce people and all
their fruit and vegetables they're
making it seem like it's all organic and
you know and I'm sure some of that is
true but still the amount of mom and
pops that are going to go under and the
farms that are gonna go under because
you but we just want cheap [ __ ] yeah
right I beg you the service was so
shitty the other day because they were
all busy pouring out count
no I I mean if I the thing is in Los
Angeles I feel like walmart doesn't
really have a strong presence so I feel
like it's like just does it even hardly
hardly exists I feel like reinert our
target or targets oh yeah our jet yeah
Jeffy Afghan fancy yeah that has really
taken over yeah and diary feel better at
all right now interestingly tarjay or
Target or target has done some anti gay
stuff not to bring everything around to
gay but so has members of the LGBT
community how do you guys feel about
like I won't go to chick-fil-a but I do
go to target so what does that say I
mean we're it's not gonna stop us write
what you know what I need I stop what am
I we're still gonna be gay and bi at the
end of the day communique and what a
good deal is possible that's what I'm
saying is that funny people want gay
people to like stand up for everything
all the time it oh we got to always be
better i'm like sick of being better or
like I want to 41 deodorant right you
know yeah debate we're doing I don't
know but I'm gonna go out there yeah
we're gonna all go after win do a little
trip
you